this is the m1 mac mini and this is
quite possibly the m1 mac mini killer
because it just came out and it has the
highest end 5900 hx processor with their
best apu graphics at the same price so
today we're gonna see not only how this
performs in benchmarks which i know it's
gonna be amazing but how it does in real
world use such as web browsing photo
editing video editing gaming and more as
i mentioned the prices are identical at
900
and this also has 16 gigabytes of ram
and 256 gigabytes of ssd now my mac mini
doesn't have a 10 gigabit either an
option which is an extra 100
but this thing does come with 2.5 gig
lamp now footprint wise they are about
the same as you guys could see
but this amd mini pc is quite a bit
thicker now there is one other important
detail and that is the fact that with
this mini pc you have to deal with this
massive power brick which it's all built
right into this ultra slim mini mac mini
it looks like this is a 120 watt power
supply whereas our mac mini actually has
one that's 150 watts built inside of it
but we all know that the mac mini only
uses up to 39 watts when it's completely
maxed out the hx90 mini pc has a ton of
ports on the back and as you see we have
multiple display outputs so you're not
going to be limited to just two displays
now of course we don't have thunderbolt
but it is odd that we don't have any usb
type-c outputs there but if we spin it
around we do have just one built-in
along with extra ports on the front so
if you like ports this thing has it and
the last thing in the box is the stand
if you're somebody that prefers to have
a vertical system
but enough talking let's go ahead and
boot this up and start comparing these
here we are all set up and i'm running
geekbench 5 to start to get a baseline
and while this is running and i'm
hearing that fan spin up now in the
multi-core section you guys see we have
16 gigs of ram we have a 5900 hx
processor with eight high performance
scores that have a base of 3.3 gigahertz
but up to 4.6 now the m1 mac mini runs
at 3.2 gigahertz flat and we have four
high performance cores and four
efficiency cores that don't really do
that much all right we have our scores
in
that's not too bad for single core we
have 1321 compared to
1753. that's a difference of 32 percent
in favor of the m1 mac mini thanks to
its efficient five nanometer chip and on
the multi-core side we're also looking
at about a difference of 20
once again the m1 mac mini is winning
but keep in mind this is a huge range of
different tasks including machine
learning so we will be testing out raw
max performance but first i want to go
to speedometer browser benchmark and
let's go ahead and get running this just
shows how responsive the system is
especially for web browsing the m1 max
are incredibly snappy way faster than
our other macs that we have we have a
score of 149 that is right in line with
the 2018 i7 mac mini but the new m1
scores 236
it is a beast at being really quick and
responsive and now let's get serious
let's start running the 10 minutes in a
bench benchmark here which is going to
test thermal throttling and also the
maximum performance this is where the
zen 3 chipsets are amazing let's see
what oh my goodness
that is crazy you guys see that we hit
63 watts running at 54.
you might be able to hear that we should
denoise the audio but that thing is
getting loud it's still sticking
at 60 54 watts right there now the m1
mac mini runs at 15 watts maximum
compared to 54 and hitting a peak of
right there
65. that is crazy now as far as the
frequency right now we're running just
over four gigahertz on eight cores
compared to 3.2 on the m1 mac mini and
it is flying through this test as far as
temperatures we're looking at 90 degrees
celsius right here
with that fan spinning loud let's look
at it basically the fan is maxed out on
the cpu so i'm guessing we're going to
get some thermal throttling here because
that is just so much power in a small
system now the m1 mac mini i think it
maxes out like 64 67 celsius under full
load and it's completely silent because
of how little wattage how little power
it uses we are almost done and it just
now dipped to 45 watts on the package
here it actually says 50 on the core is
higher but it was over 50 that whole
time running at 90 degrees celsius so
looks like it gives you a huge amount of
performance and only at about the 10
minute mark is when it actually starts
slowing down and gets itself cooler at
84 85 degrees and bam we have our
results we're looking at 10
680 points that is killing our mac pros
7
7717 points that is over 60 percent more
cpu performance which is crazy of course
it did use a lot more power if we
calculate the points per watt we get 205
points per watt compared to
594 it's almost three times better
performance for the wattage with the m1
mac mini now before we go ahead and see
how this actually translates to real
world say video editing photo editing
let's take a look at the graphics we'll
start out with geekbench and then we'll
do the new gaming test let's switch over
to vulkan for better efficiency of
course we're using metal on the m1 mac
mini keep in mind this thing has the
latest and best integrated graphics chip
that amd makes with these new high-end
super nice processors compared to apples
this has the eight core unit and that is
their entry level m1 chip obviously
we're waiting for the m1x but let's see
how these do all right not bad we have a
score of 16 302 compared to 20 2007 18
on the m1 mac mini so that's a
difference about 39
in a wide variety of tasks that
geekbench test so now let's go ahead and
do a test with some gaming of course
with the mac we don't have a lot of
high-end games but with windows you do
so let's see how they performs running
the brand new 3dmark wildlife extreme
unlimited test that will give us modern
results so unfortunately no matter what
i try it keeps crashing on me i made
sure to have the latest updates for uh
graphics and it's just not working so
we're going to go to plan b we're going
to open up gfx bench we are going to run
1440p aztec runes off-screen to keep it
fair all right let's see what the
results say this is tiny on here because
of windows scaling
32.35 frames per second
now guess how much the m1 does you guys
can comment down below if you already
know you know it gets 71.1
that is over twice as fast now with all
of that taken care of let's go ahead and
get into some more real world stuff i'm
going to start out with photo editing
with all of those high performance cores
high frequency and high wattage it
should do a great job for photo editing
and exporting these are 42 megapixel raw
files with a bunch of effects already
added and as we flip through
okay it's pretty quick probably about
the same as the m1 maybe even slightly
faster
okay that is great let's go ahead and
open up a brush here check out the
smoothness
and
uh
it's okay it's a little bit laggy there
at the start the m1 does that as well
but then you still get a little bit of
lag okay so there you go now it smooths
out so it does take a little bit longer
to smooth out and that is likely because
of the graphics now let's go ahead and
select all 50 of these images this is
where that amd processor should come
into its own let's hit the export button
i'm going to start the timer and i'm
curious to see
what that 50 watts or more going to
eight cores at four over four gigahertz
will do and now of course on the m1
it's a lot lower but we also have
optimizations
and eight channels of memory compared to
dual channel which is crazy the apple
pulled it off you guys have to check out
that and antec article all right guys we
are rolling
but based on the time
i don't know it's gonna be interesting
here you guys could see the cpu's maxed
out it's actually running at 4.3
gigahertz on all a cores 100
the gpu is fluctuating uh based on what
it's doing for graphics but it's mostly
cpu
ram is at 13 gigs remember both have 16
gigs of ram
let's see what the end result will be
all right guys we are almost done there
it's at a hundred percent bam okay
the fans are blasting the cpus are going
at full speed
our m1 mac mini takes two minutes and 37
seconds to export all of these
let's see what this gets it gets three
minutes and 33 seconds so the same
amount of ram
way more powerful cpu you guys saw over
60 it was like 64 more powerful in
cinebench and that's when it's doing one
task maxing out all the cpus here it
actually ran faster as far as frequency
but still
because of optimizations
because it's running through metal and
the ram setup the apple is using as far
as the channels
it smokes it the extra cp performance
the extra 54 watts instead of 15 doesn't
matter
this thing just got smoked that is crazy
so as far as smoothness editing very
similar to exporting absolutely wins the
same thing with doing previews if you're
going to do
the new ai up scaling feature
crazy so now let's go ahead and close
lightroom and let's take a look at video
editing let's start out by stabilizing a
20 second 4k clip we do this all the
time so it looks like it took almost 10
seconds there to start usually it's a
couple seconds but maybe it's longer
with this setup
and bam that is done
so the m1
now with davinci resolve it takes 30
seconds to do this and that is with a
few seconds of it starting up
this thing just took
1 minute and 10 seconds so even if we
take out the 10 seconds it took to start
instead of 3 4 5 seconds let's say we're
still at a minute that is still
twice as long as the m1 mac mini which
is crazy now how about just playing back
in the timeline when you're editing this
is standard 4k footage couple luts for
color corrections and then some film
crane
um okay
well you guys see that right there that
is not good at all the m1 plays this
back perfectly so it's definitely not
handling this very well let's see how
long it takes to export this five minute
project here and that took eight minutes
and 32 seconds compared to three minutes
and nine seconds so the m1 is more than
twice as fast getting close to three
times faster than the amd cpu now i
wanted to make sure that i'm not doing
anything wrong because i was expecting
way better performance than this so i
double checked the gpu is being used it
looks like we get access to up to 6.1
gigs of video memory from the 16 gig
total there i was using amd the decoders
built to the amd graphics card which is
what's faster we're not using cpu
encoding
that is just not great results so let's
switch over to hdr265 this is more
efficient maybe it will do better with
this kodak so we're playing back here
you guys see that stuttering
it is not playing back any smoother with
the m1 this is actually faster now with
the new decoders and encoders
not great let's just do one more export
it does look like it's going a little
bit faster now right at the gate it's
saying we have just over six minutes
remaining let's go ahead and see
how it will do
but let me tell you guys what it doesn't
matter if it's gonna take six minutes
here because the m1 is absolutely insane
with this six minutes and two seconds
compared to one minute and 23 seconds so
i was gonna keep going i want to do some
raw video editing but no i think i have
to stop because it's just gonna get way
too crazy the distances the performance
difference is just gonna get greater and
greater the heavier the projects are
so wow what does that really tell us
well
we can have an amd system seven
nanometers zen three amazing high
wattage unlocked blaring and we can have
their best graphics
great deal but it cannot touch the m1
sure in some benchmarks it can beat it
out
but when it comes to real world
performance when we're actually doing
work with software
you can't touch the m1s it is just
incredible what performance they give
you
but you guys let me know your thoughts
down in the comment section below click
that circle above to subscribe check out
one of those great videos right over
there that's been max and i will see you
in the next video
[Music]